so we're gonna get some chairs up on
stage along with our wonderful panelists
while we're doing that while we're
getting set up we're gonna talk a bit
about building with empathy I would
imagine not many of you guys talk about
this on a daily basis or in your 2018
planning or anything like that so I
thought it's been a couple of minutes
just teeing up what that means and and
some perspectives and what we're gonna
talk about thank you so empathy the
ability to understand and share the
feelings of another the American
Association of psychology proposes it's
the defining trait that makes us human
and the absence of which enables things
like oppression persecution violence
warfare all the rotten things in life so
I think on a personal level on a
one-to-one basis we would all we all
agree that it's an incredibly important
quality and something that I hope we all
will try to exude in daily lives but
what does it mean on a business level
what does it mean if you're building
products making decisions every day can
you do that with empathy and and does it
matter should you do that what are the
costs of not doing that or doing that
and they're really kind of two key
perspectives to think about this one is
as the business decision maker or the
product decision maker can you be
empathy driven you know we talked about
data driven all the time and we use it
as a positive trait you know he's data
driven and it's amazing but we rarely
talk about being empathy driven and
thinking about that in your decision
making and an example that came to mind
when thinking about this was Wonder
Bread and I don't know how many I didn't
grow up in the u.s. so for me Wonder
Bread was kind of a revelation when I
moved it moved here I've never tasted it
but they they pioneered sliced bread in
the 1920s you know they were kind of a
seen as a huge innovator in the food
industry the term the best thing since
sliced bread sliced bread was from
Wonder Bread they saw huge success in
the nineteen nineteen 50s and 60s about
25 to 30 percent of American caloric
intake was Wonder Bread nothing nothing
has been as prolific since then you know
not not coca-cola not high fructose corn
syrup in 2012 they filed for bankruptcy
and you know obviously many many reasons
for that but one of the main reasons
that's suggested is the rise of health
food organic food as supplements
mentioning greater awareness and if you
were a product manager at Wonder Bread
in the 1950s and you proposed to do an
a/b test to sell whole-wheat bread I
wonder how many of us would would have
been successful with a a B test or
whether the leadership of the company
would have been all it's a great idea go
ahead with that and I think that what
what what's what's what's interesting is
that often there can be a trade-off
potentially between performance and
building a better experience a more
enriching experience for your users and
how do you how do you make that
trade-off and how do you even know if
you're going in the right direction and
the other perspective which is
incredibly relevant to you'll as
technology product managers decision
makers is the need to build products
with empathy now with the rise of voice
search we're seeing over a billion voice
queries on Google now per week with
assistants and AI and new models of
engaging with users and natural language
processing users expect your product to
behave like a person and more than that
to behave like a friend and your friend
isn't always nice to you your friend is
not robotic kind of answering in binary
ones and zeros your friend understands
you and the same you don't expect the
same so you might have a friend who she
expects to play have a certain way I
have a different expectation like we saw
in the I do video so it's a very
challenging challenging problem so with
that I would love to introduce my three
wonderful panelists as you guys do quick
intros I'm gonna scan through images of
your products so you guys can can can
talk a bit about that go ahead well
thanks for having us here today hi
everyone my name is Aisha Gupta I am a
co-founder and the director of content
at hooked which is a chat fiction app we
currently have 30 million readers and
our goal with hooked is to redefine the
way that people read and write and
consume fiction stories on their phones
hi I'm Sam Mandel I'm the CEO of pancho
I'm also a partner of beta works which
is a start-up studio in New York for a
Pancho was created our goal of pancho is
to
new weather service aimed at Millennials
and younger people but as we thought
about what that meant we decided we
wanted to create sort of a kind of
experience of getting the weather from a
friend or a friendly acquaintance or
something in that category and we're
really trying to do two things one is
figure out what it means to have native
content for the messaging layer because
we felt like that's where Pancho should
really live and the other is eventually
how to build kind of a UI that would
work for sort of AI backends and how it
could bring that sort of friendliness on
the front end to more data-driven and
sort of assembling sort of a data
package like weather now one of the ways
we do that we actually have two comedy
writers on our team and they they're
comedians by night and write for poncho
by day and they actually write the
forecast but everything else we do with
poncho is sort of done done
algorithmically both on our on our apps
for iOS and Android and also we we have
one of the best chat BOTS out there on
Facebook messenger and a couple of other
platforms in fact we just got our webby
award yesterday finally came in the mail
and it said world's best chat bot on its
- well I hope you're sharing it with
poncho I'm Danielle I run Google's
empathy lab and the way that that kind
of works at a place like Google as I
work with our research and machine
intelligence gang sort of on all of the
the guts and the intelligence the souls
of these things also with the assistant
gang and then I'm deeply embedded in the
design organization as well because you
know everybody needs some empathy so so
basically I yeah I work across all of
those teams and connecting those teams
kind of as the glue and a way that I
often talk about my work is Google is
incredible
at IQ and what we're really starting to
build and develop at this point as our
EQ because you can imagine if our EQ is
equal to our IQ how compelling the
spaces and I think for this new design
paradigm which is about sort of
interaction relationship it's it's like
it is an imperative now rather than
something that's just like oh it's this
like squishy layer or like sort of like
design once
is this like great thing that some
people got and other people didn't it's
like we're at that stage with this it's
like are we can I acknowledge what's
really happening here so awesome well
well thank you all so much for being
here
each I'd love to start with you you know
hooked given its its focus on chat
stories you know stories are inherently
kind of empathetic and all about
relating to one another was building
your products with that in mind and
building kind of a personality and your
product an obvious endeavor or was it
something that kind of had to come about
and you have to kind of make big product
decisions to decide how to how to do
that within the UI yeah that's a great
question
um so I think the short answer to that
is it there there wasn't a lot of
conscious discussion or decision around
building a personality into the app I
think we think about it more in terms of
what is I guess the personality of the
main character of a story and how does
that speak to the audience we're trying
to target that story too
but what I will say and I just want to
circle back and kind of piggyback off of
the Wonder Bread analogy because I just
think it's so good and it made me as you
were saying it think about maybe we're
kind of experiencing like our Wonder
Bread moment with mobile and in and what
I mean by that is you know we've sort of
had this first slew of apps that have
come out that are really addicting and
we're using them constantly and they're
really entertaining but perhaps they
leave us feeling a little bit
dissatisfied and and kind of unhappy at
times you know we probably were at peak
social we're all maybe spending a lot
more time on social media than we like
and that experience I think sometimes
leaves us feeling just like there's a
lack of something and so in many ways
that that is the reason why we started
hooked
we felt like we wanted to be kind of a
whole wheat option and you know there
isn't sort of a lot of there isn't a lot
of options out there that feel like a
nourishing alternative to what is out
there and so yeah so I think with that
in mind you know we thought okay well
there are many studies that show that
there's a high correlation between the
amount of fiction a person consumes and
their ability to score high
or highly or well on tests that measure
empathy and social skills and even
happiness and so you take that idea in
and of itself plus just are the team's
personal experience of reading and
feeling like you're sort of building
empathy and and in this meditative state
so how do you take those facts and
experiences and translate them into an
experience for mobile basically and so
that's kind of like where our whole
journey started and I think you know
from our perspective too it's like you
can't really expect us to put down our
phones I don't think that we're gonna
ever reach a point where we're gonna
live in a digital detox and so that said
it's sort of like okay how do you how do
you start creating those more nourishing
like wholewheat options that still taste
really good and are really really
addicting but also leave you feeling
better than maybe the wonder breads of
the world I like that you carried that
through maybe we'll just have goggles
and then you know who needs to hold
anything Sam you're the token male on
the panel so thank you for being that
that's great for a change I'm so you're
approaching this kind of with two hats
you know Poncho's a startup and you also
advise other companies as well as
startups do you find that given you know
a world resource constrained but
especially to startup kind of you got to
make trade-offs
do you find it have you ever had to make
those tough decisions between like well
we need to really grow our core metric
whatever that is right now and it could
be at the expense of this really
enriching engaging you know experience
that we spend all our time building or
you always kind of know at your heart
that the pancho character and investing
in that and the comedic side of it is is
always going to trump more money more
more engagement you know we're just
reaching that point now in our history I
think up till now it's been easy because
really engagement was the core metric
were used internally and engagement a
retention and we felt like that was the
best our goal was to become part of
people's daily routine you know you see
the average user like twice a day we've
you know we have I think by far the
highest chatbot retention of I think any
bot and our app retention is very very
high too and so we sort of
those goals and what we were measuring
sort of reinforced this idea that we
wanted to be friends with the user not
abuse that relationship when we send
notifications we specifically designed
them so you don't have to open them one
of our when the other weather app sort
of sends one saying like check out the
weather say and we actually give you the
weather so that you know that our use
case paradigm is sort of you're in bed
in the morning you're looking at your
texts and messages from your friends and
you have one from poncho that tells you
the weather and so that that was you
know we we didn't have to really push it
now we're now we're just starting a
project where we're gonna try and sell
have punch-out sell things to you and so
we really and we know that not all users
are gonna like that and we have to
figure out you know we think of poncho
is a virtual influencer we want to build
build him up as a character who you'll
can relate to and buy things from and so
the way we've approached that we've done
some experiments and and there was
definitely some user pushback we're now
going to we're now doing a bigger series
of tests basically towards launching a
launching a product that's going to have
some poncho branding on it that we're
doing in partnership and the first thing
we do is create sort of a backstory for
why it's happening we have a character
Bible for poncho that we've written and
most of that's not really visible to the
users like I know Poncho's major in
college which was Canadian film we've
never revealed that to the user but it
just serves us it just helps us sort of
get in the mood for like is this
something he would do is it something
you'd not do and that has to do with
kind of creating someone who he's sort
of a friend but we think of him was
almost between a friend an acquaintance
sort of like he's not he's not your best
friend but he's somebody you're friendly
with and so we thought okay well why
would he be selling this well and and
now now we're gonna go forward and
basically do a lot of a/b testing in
terms of with subsets of our users to
see what there's the most pushback to
but we always want to be transparent
about it and one of a big part of that
story is gonna be that like Poncho's
rent went up and if he lives in Brooklyn
we have to he's got to make his rent
he's and his job at panco Inc where he
works
he's not cutting it so he's got this
kind of side gig and then we're gonna
test like how much of that we exposed to
the users I think your goal is to sell
the product it's not necessarily to be
consistent with the story although the
writers and you know the whole team the
engineers - we all get into kind of the
story and we always have to fight that
temptation to surface too much of that
and our goal is to surface sort of just
enough of it so that that we don't get
this pushback but we do think of
ourselves as being sort of in a
relationship with the user and we think
that that drives a lot of our retention
because people feel like if they delete
the pancho app or something they just
feel they feel a little guilty about it
and and so we want to approach even sort
of things that the user might not not be
might not be their first choice to see
sort of advertising or commerce and
pancho but we want to be transparent in
a way that's treated the character about
why we're doing at and and that so we'll
just see how that goes but we're trying
to do that in the same spirit as we've
designed the rest of the service so you
talked about testing and Daniel I
imagine this must be like a Herculean
feat at Google to try to get people out
of the mindset of purely you know
data-driven you know there's 60 60
whatever here in 59-year we're going
with the 60 how have you approached
moving people into more of an EQ
measurement mindset and are you doing
that quantifiably have you found ways to
do that or is it does it need to be more
qualitative and about you know see sad
and and softer metrics it's gotta be all
of it I mean the thing the thing that
kind of is like you know the the
blessing and the curse of this space is
that it's it's invisible it's we're
trying to literally make things visible
that are invisible we're also trying to
make things comfortable that are
uncomfortable like in terms of talking
about feelings it's like I literally
will just walk into a room and be like
we're gonna talk about feelings people
are like face-melting terror right so I
think what's kind of just tackling that
head-on and saying humans are messy
there's the rational and the irrational
there's the stuff that makes sense
there's the stuff you can research
that's unresearched ball the whole point
of talking to people and understanding
the full story like there was a there
was a great line from a psychologist
that I work with who was basically like
the only way that you can know a person
and to truly know them is when you know
their story so when we look at the full
story some of that is going to be the
pattern recognition and the metrics and
some of it is going to be all of the
narrative super glue and messiness that
kind of makes them in their life and so
what I make a big point of doing in my
conversations with our gang at Google is
is to quote the Martian and science the
out of it so I what I tend to do is
speak a lot about the way people feel
and experience things and I get into a
lot of that I make a lot of you know
short documentary films that sort of let
people tell their own stories and really
when you think about films you're making
feelings like in the in the other person
when you're telling a story you're
making feelings and so what I try to do
is have though those stories tell
themselves and then there's so much
around emotional intelligence and social
intelligence and you know the psychology
of these spaces that what I find myself
doing is instead of trying to invent new
metrics is to look at the metrics that
are out there around machine
intelligence and the idea of learning
someone and growing some you know
growing with someone and getting to know
them better and a hit or a miss and then
fill that in with things like the
Gottman's method so show of hands for
folks in the room that know the
Gottman's means you all probably have
wonderful marriages so the Guttman's got
famous in the 90s for basically they
were the people where you could sit down
with them for 20 minutes and they would
tell you like how long your marriage was
gonna last
they had their love lab like a fortune
teller how would they know they they
basically it's they were all the kind of
micro gestures and like all of that
stuff and then also just like galvanic
skin you know all the lab' stuff but
they could literally sit with you for 20
minutes and be like you guys aren't
gonna make it you'll make it seven years
they'll make it 14 years and I mean like
can you imagine this dress like the
worst dinner party guests ever
but what's rad about what they did is
they also became known for like kind of
in the 90s zone divorce was hockey
sticking this idea of
the magic ratio which is five to one and
so the way that that works is for every
five positive interactions that you have
it's okay if there's one bad one and
what was interesting about this is it
was like basically agnostic to coupling
style people were like oh my god if we
like you know fight all the time but we
make up all the time is that better than
if we're like conflict averse or is it
worse or like who's gonna make it was
like the fear like people care about
their relationships and they were like
it doesn't matter what matters is the
ratio it's like the you know people have
used like the piggy bank you know
putting points in the bank and all that
stuff other metaphors for it
but I think what's interesting about
that is I've run a lot of research
saying well if we're in a paradigm where
this is this is the interface and it's a
relationship driven then like the rules
for relationships and what works should
borrow over here and what I found is
like that five to one metric bears out
so when you're designing the research
how are you asking the right narrative
questions to get at the truth I mean
like I immediately I'm like oh my god I
wonder if people with poncho we're gonna
be like how's the side hustle going man
like in the morning like if I were to
get a text from him I'd be like how's it
going and these types of things how do
you design for that messy space and at
the same time be looking at the really
core architectures of what feels right
in a relationship the five to one is
just like when it feels right I feel
like I'm constantly trying to find ways
to put pins on things that like are the
most uncomfortable weird parts of being
human yeah I can I just say when we
designed the punch robot I've never
heard of that five to one ratio I'm sure
another team knows it but we just
decided that we had to basically if you
asked punch of the poncho bought a
question about the weather we had to
understand that 80% of the time and if
we couldn't do that then we weren't
succeeding and so it's kind of funny
that that we just but we as collectively
sat around we were like that's the
metric that we have to go for that's
such a good point too because I think
you guys intuitively got there and
that's kind of like you know head bleep
of this space is like if you if you
really like check-in if you if you drop
in you we all know the answers of what
feels good what doesn't feel good what
we believe what we don't what story like
actually like I mean literally using
your app I was
oh my god it's not loading fast enough
like why doesn't this story text me
faster and that sense of when when
you're in it versus when you're out of
it and I think it's how do we find
metrics that actually match that versus
being driven by what's the like what's
the actual best metric for this thing we
can kind of get lost in our heads like a
big thing I talk about is how we often
think that we're designing for people's
modes like you know airplane mode this
that what game mode stress mode
I think what's funny is people when they
like a research project I ran that you
know about was um I was like okay it's
really weird to ask people what their
ideal flow of information is for
notifications and this that and the
other and people were kind of asking me
about the tray and I was like okay
forgot the tray like I went to people
and was like you know you know what
airplane mode is give me like ten more
and all of their modes were moods they
weren't modes at all so just that like
little the extra Oh makes a difference I
think like intuitively being like oh I
think that's right how do I make a
metric for that yeah you talked about
kind of you know maybe mimicking a great
relationship or you've got kind of this
you know good ratio of positive and
negative but in that paradigm you know
you as a person that relationship you're
you are yourself you can't you're not a
machine you can't switch who you are and
have an equally effective relationship
with somebody else you can do that in
your product right so you can be a
different person to it to one user and
another to another user is that I guess
how do you think about that when you're
built and you know for others in the
audience who are either building your
own natural language interface or are
you just kind of thinking about your
brand personality do you stay as one
brand or do you mimic whatever the user
wants and what are the trade-offs there
and how do you guys think about that
yeah well I'll jump in here and say that
one interesting thing that happened in
the past year with hooked that we
noticed is that when we first started
collecting stories for the app our main
goal was to get stories that were super
addicting because we're like okay goal
is to get people to read how do you do
that you need like BuzzFeed of fiction
you need it to be super addicting people
want to tap get to the end and so when
we first started out we incentivized
authors for that particular metric the
metric of success we were measuring was
completion rate of stories
and so we collected a bunch of stories
that had really high engagement and you
know we thought all was going well and
then we ran sentiment analysis after we
had a good collection of stories I think
about like 200 250 on the comments and
the likes to loves ratios and like you
know the word the positive to negative
words in the comments we just you know
ran a huge analysis of can we gauge and
what people actually feel about this
story and what we learned is that people
hated cliffhanger endings they were so
angry that they would get to the end of
his story and it wouldn't have this like
resolute kind of satisfying ending and
they fell almost betrayed and so what we
saw is that well first of all it's
really hard to write a good ending to
any story that's just like a challenge
of writing a good fiction story but it's
particularly challenging in a compressed
format with the goal of being super
engaging in such a short amount of time
and so we kind of went back to the
drawing board and we're like okay this
is clearly important from an emotional
perspective for our readers and so we
changed our incentive structure and and
asked authors to revisit their stories
and then moving forward like really
invest in thinking about how to write
endings with more closure and then we
reran the sentiment analysis and user
satisfaction just like shot way up and
so I use the Sun as an example because I
think it wasn't though in retrospect
it's obvious it wasn't something we were
really thinking about in the beginning
and this was something we heard from our
readers you know like across the board
that they wanted and so we did sort of
maneuver ourselves to cater to that
because what it taught us is that
measuring based on just one metric
engagement isn't enough we have to
always ask ourself with every story what
is the emotional experience that this
person is potentially having with this
piece as a whole is it good or is it bad
and if it's bad we need to figure out
how to make it good yeah yeah imagine I
don't know if any media producers are in
the room and Netflix I have a bone to
pick with every original content piece
because everything is a cliffhanger and
it forces you to keep keep staying
addicted to a specific show but I mean I
think it goes back to you know whether
users are not necessarily go
a positive feeling after their
interaction with your product and is
that do you always want to make the user
happy I guess I know that's a strange
question but you know in real life the
people who you want to be around all the
time don't always kind of just kind of
placate to your tier you know every need
to keep you smiling I think in the in
the I do study there was the example of
somebody who said they wanted somebody
to challenge them or kind of you know
not not let them get away with doing
whatever they want is that something
that you can build in and should build
and build into products I don't know
maybe this isn't the exact same question
you're asking but we we've looked we
look at a lot of the digital assistants
because pancho is kind of a digital
assistant in some ways and one of the
things we consciously decided we didn't
want to do with pancho is make them to
accommodate it um you know because I
think that one of the one of the issues
with digital assistants is that they're
they're pretty subservience and and when
and because they all have female
personalities it's sort of like even
worse and you know it just there's just
some I think they can get a little
creepy and they're also not human
because humans that the Google assistant
right the Google system
I like the Google system because it's so
dry like it's sort of it feels more
robotic and in a good way but like it's
not trying to do anything else but I
think that are you saying this because
I'm sitting right now but I think that
Google have a certain dryness I really
do mean that in a positive way like it's
not pretending to be a person exactly
but the but I think that with um with
poncho we decided like he he's gonna be
somebody who you're not he's not your
best friend guesses on things to do so
even little messages sometimes like if
when you talk to the chat bot he's like
hey I was charging my phone sorry you
know I didn't see you there or something
like that like like what was that sorry
to interrupt you but was that an obvious
choice to think of him as you didn't
want him to be your best friend
we didn't want him to be servile we
wanted him someone who you wanted to be
friends with like he was like a little
cooler than you and you were sort of
like trying to like you know that we
wanted to have that relationship because
we thought that was just more intriguing
and we'd sort of people would be we
always want people to kind of try to
know more now that being said we want
their reaction when they've used pancho
like our user promise is
sort of moment of Zen in the morning and
you know we think about what that our
use case is basically morning you so the
average user we have like two sessions a
day per user but um we think about that
morning use case is fundamental and we
want especially now like things have
just gotten worse like you dread opening
your phone you know who that's what's in
the news we just want that moment to be
to leave you with a little bit of a
smile and that's kind of our brand
promise so if we don't if we don't
succeed there then we're not we're not
delivering what we've promised it in I
think another way to answer your
question too and is about like the the
identity being elastic having a sense of
elasticity to it so that it can change
over time in a narrative arc so that it
can change in skills that are added or
things like conscious side hustle
I think what's the thing that we know to
be like most true about humans is that
we change and we're never one thing and
just when we think we figured our selves
out or we're kind of not that like
learning and growing and figuring it out
and not feeling like you have anything
figured out and like the human
experience being like this whether you
screenshot it as a day or whether you
look at it as a movie arc I mean boyhood
and et or two of the like I have two
four minute edits for both of those that
I use constantly when I talk about
machine learning and the reason why is
that we understand growth and change and
variability and personality and when
things are great and one things suck and
the fact that all of that's welcome we
understand that in the context of each
other and stories and if you can apply
backstory and background and narrative
and like tech isn't perfect and
assistance won't be perfect and the
weather is unpredictable and it may be
punches mysterious or you know the
assistance this or that I think just
that sense of the best speakers the best
films the things that really move you
and you feel connected to that bond is
because they make you feel a little bit
of everything yep and I think that
little bit of everything is something
that you design and with a light hand
but an assistant that is a cheerleader
and is always kind of a positive thing
would like drive you crazy
it would be like Reese Witherspoon from
election following him around know right
so I think
we often want to go to the positive high
note place but that's not where we live
so how do we get really authentic and
vulnerable about that and like designing
for those spaces with these I mean the
thing about devices and our experiences
with these presences now is its 24/7 the
on/off switch is a joke they're
everywhere so we need a lot more
granularity and gradient in that aspect
of the experience emotionally now yeah
we only a couple minutes I would love I
I don't know how many of you and the
audience do a lot of thinking in this
space or if you already have you know
kind of ways to measure longer-term
empathy emotion all that if not you know
what would you guys give as advice you
know as you guys have started thinking
about this if you were doing it again
from scratch or just starting this what
are some things that you would recommend
to anyone in that position I guess this
is maybe gonna sound generic we as a
team internally often are debating which
direction to go it's usually a 50/50
split and we'll have emotional reactions
to what we think we should do but then
we always just kind of settle back into
just testing it and and and seeing what
the results are but when they're closed
taking it with a grain of salt
you know and so like for the ending of
stories ultimately financially it wasn't
a great decision because we had to pay
our authors more for the same amount of
stories but like we decided that kind of
based on just like the negativity
surrounding the emotional experience for
our readers that it might be something
worth doing and even though maybe there
isn't an actual data point around how
its increased our revenue from a like
you know from that perspective the point
is users seem happier and so therefore
for us it's a win and so I think I don't
know there's not like it emotions are
like Danielle's saying it's you can't
measure them with quite as much
granularity and so I fester intuition
you just have to trust your intuition
it's like does this thing make me feel
shitty or it doesn't make me feel good
you know and if the answer is like
pretty clear I feel like that should be
the thing that helps you point your ear
out either direction so I'm Danielle do
you guys have words of wisdom for new
entrance to the space I think well I'd
say like two things like we all know
that moment in the movie where you're
like don't go in there
there's this thing where I think as
we're designing stuff it's like when
you're following your feelings when
you're in an experience like your
intuition whether you're someone that
like acknowledges that or not is in play
and I think when we tend to design stuff
we look at it within the container so
it's like blow away the container and
then I think the other piece of that is
the invitation for you as a you know in
whatever function or discipline you're
in is to like we really do need to tap
all of our humanities we're working on
these things like with this interaction
space you're not just the designer the
researcher the PM or whatever you've got
to bring the human piece because it's
the mess that's gonna make this stuff
believable it's gonna make it compelling
and it's gonna make it welcome because I
think the end game of all of this that's
potentially there is like this world can
either feel really harmonious with all
of these kind of helpful agents and
friends and things it's like your social
circle expands or it's like total
schizophrenia so that's like where you
know in 1987 like Apple had their HCI
principles and were like here's how this
needs to work and I think we're all
we're working on that recipe together
right now mm-hmm
I would just say I've always wanted to I
was a philosophy major in college so I
I'm gonna quote Immanuel Kant the great
German philosopher and probably never
been done a Google event before of it he
had this thing where he said like you
treat people ethically you should treat
them as ends in themselves not as a
means to an end and I do think about
that in terms of like app design and
product design you know we shouldn't
think of our of our users as means to
like our end where we're trying to drive
certain metrics you know we try to think
okay what do they want to do and are we
helping them do that and that's kind of
our that's our fundamental design
principle wise words thank you all so
much for joining us in a segue we're
actually going to be talking to Brad or
Brad is gonna be talking about the
assistant so very relevant to this
conversation yeah thank you again thanks
everyone for being here
you